[Musique]
les mêmes scènes se répètent dans le
ciel de gaza
signe de l' escalade de la violence des
dizaines de roquettes ont à nouveau été
tirés vers le territoire d'israël
de leur côté des centaines de gazaouis
ont fait leur logement pour se mettre à
l'abri des bombardements israéliens des
forces israéliennes qui ont resserré
hier leur étau sur la bande de gaza les
chars et véhicules blindés de tsahal se
sont positionnés tout autour de
l'enclavé palestinienne
les forces de l'état hébreu ont
d'ailleurs annoncé cette nuit la
présence de leurs soldats dans le
territoire avant de se rétracter
mais israël semble se préparer à toute
éventualité
9000 réservistes ont été appelés à se
mobiliser en vue d'une éventuelle
opération terrestre
le premier ministre israélien a lui tenu
à réaffirmer sa détermination à lutter
contre le ramasser ses alliés j'ai dit
que nous ferions payé un prix très lourd
au hamas et aux autres organisations
terroristes et nous continuerons à le
faire avec une grande force nous n'avons
pas dit notre dernier mot et cette
opération se poursuivra aussi longtemps
que nécessaire afin de rétablir le calme
et la sécurité de l'état d'israël
face à la détermination israélienne les
groupes armés gazaouis se disent prêts à
poursuivre les combats
le ramasse a ainsi appelé les compagnies
aériennes à suspendre leurs vols vers
israël les autorités ont d'ailleurs des
routes et les vols vers l'aéroport
international ben gourion de tel aviv
s'il s'agit de répondre à votre
agression et de revendiquer la victoire
pour notre peuple et nos valeurs sacrées
il n'y a pas de lignes rouges de règles
d'engagement sacré ou de calculs
compliqués
la violence qui se répand également dans
les villes israéliennes où cohabitent et
jusqu'à présent pacifiquement les
communautés arabes et juives
symbole de ces tensions la ville de lod
où des affrontements ont lieu depuis
plusieurs jours au milieu des carcasses
de voitures brûlées les arrestations se
multiplient cette semaine un père de
famille arabe a été tué après avoir été
poursuivi par des extrémistes hier c'est
une synagogue qui a été brûlé pour
tenter de ramener le calme dans ces
villes dites mixtes près de 1000 agents
de la police des frontières ont été
appelés en renfort